maxime guignard d'un rendez vous galant
maxime kenny est en place maxime gainey
dans tpm pea ya pas l'air bien car elle
est pire alors ya sa chérie à côté face
à cherry la personne
voilà qui s'est permis de calmer le
retrait michaud cravate adjoint jean
claude van damme calme aurait alors yann
yousra qui est avec lui maxime est ce
que ça va mon chéri qu'est ce que c'est
que cette mascarade
qu'est ce qui est à mon chéri mais
attend chez arriver là ça fait une heure
je suis athée 5 degrés je suis sur une
machine ses marques et 60 m 120 km/heure
et à yousra qui attendent avec un
plateau repas alors mot syrie je suis
très content que tu sois là vraiment je
te le dis parce que vous vouliez dîner
en tête à tête yousra histoire et ben
c'est ce que vous faites vous êtes
actuellement la foire du trône et je
vous ai prévu un petit traiteur italien
voilà vous avez de quoi manger les
cherry et vous allez manger en amoureux
tous les deux c'est le meilleur
restaurant de paris
si vous réussissez vous irez c'est mon
poto hinault mais pour l'instant
maxime c'est très simple je sais que ça
fait longtemps tu n'as pas été au
septième ciel en tout cas avec un
partenaire a mis au monde venus d'accord
mon chéri est ce que tu te sens bien
maxime n'ont pas trop vous pouvez dire
alors suis très fan des parcs
d'attractions mais pour le coup ça prend
énormément le
la hauteur ou en bas lorsque j'ai pas de
point d'appui ça me gêne un petit peu
maxime je pense que maxime s'est tu ne
veux pas le faire maxime on a on arrête
ça ça serait dommage
est ce que kaka nos de le faire là pas
masquer un voyage on a un voyage aux
canaries à faire gagner un voyage aux
canaries avait regagné messi pour
servier des voyages aux canaries faut
faire la même attraction
on va voir est ce qu'on peut faire faire
à faire faire à quelqu'un la taxe aux
pour voir ce que c'est pas à maxime pour
que je vous montre ce que c'est il
faudra le faire déguisé en canari les
yeux bandés pour faire gagner le voyage
aux canaries à un téléspectateur qui
autour de la table se sent capable de le
faire on va décharger maxime parce que
je ne sens pas bien et je veux pas que
ça devienne une terrasse vente d'objets
déco alors non je peux le faire
non le problème on me donnait un déficit
comme son clone bandeau mais bon
[Rires]
le pauvre risque alors maxime maxime moi
je te dis la vérité je te sens pas nu
des vosges talent inné blanche le saura
sera et des blancs a été arrêté mais
d'etarras matin rue madame maxime tu ne
le fera pas parce que je te sens pas
vouloir le faire si je le ferai je suis
prêt
[Applaudissements]
maxime tu vas le faire au nom de l'amour
mais juste avant sk quelqu'un après qui
est capable de le faire en canari les
yeux bandés et de faire gagner le voyage
aux canaries castaldi est ce que c'est
oui est-ce que ses dents chez nombre une
famille et non c'est pas castaldi tâche
ne peut pas il est blessé six blessés
des médailles et vous avez mal au dos
jean michel maire ça passera pas au
niveau du zizi kelly même pas en rêve je
pense bernard montiel pas assez de
soleil là où l'a annoncé gynéco
peut-être merci non pas que je n'ai reçu
quoi n'embauche non merci
isabelle je suis déjà été lavé rincer
il a fait beaucoup de choses ouais et
restaurer mais c'est vrai que c'est ma
terreur ces trucs là parce que ça donne
le vertige mais si c'est pour ces pour
une famille bon voyage aux canaries
la peur du vide antigel est ce que vous
voulez voir d'abord maxime d'accord on
va voir la voir maxime maxime où vous
allez le faire au nom de l'amour est ce
que il est obligé de garder son plateau
maxime il est assez regardé
ah oui d'accord merci de le faire c'est
pour ce faire maxime maxime c'est à vous
si pour les 9 ans élevé vous allez avoir
un des fils maxime un moment il ya youth
raquette en bas vous devrez dire
yousra je t'aime je t'aime d'accor
devrait dire ça d'accord je t'aime aussi
la collection les fourchettes et des
couteaux sont vous pouvez enlever les
fourchettes et des couteaux non c'est
raymond qui a scotché olga scotché vous
inquiétez pas m et moi enlevez moi ce
plateau là c'est trop enlevé mois et
plateau c'est trop c'est dangereux j'ai
peur du classement donc relevé voit ce
plateau dit à la production d'enlever le
plateau à maman d'enlever le bateau dont
vous allez être yousra je t'aime cilou
sera à vous réponds je t'aime aussi mon
mac sous c'est qu'on est sur l'autoroute
de l'amour
si elle vous répond non merci situerait
alors si tu réponds
merci la sève asie bah dis donc tu dis
je vais te dire si j'ai le courage je
t'aime yousra yousra d'amour et tu me
répondras où je t'aime on absout ou le
contraire ok à toi le vieux rhin ok
[Applaudissements]
je l'adorent maximas culte de maxime tu
peux me dire je veux pas le faire
il veut le faire il a dû le faire je le
faire franchement vous me donnez à
lessiver et vous voulez donner un
conseil j'allais dire yougoslavie mais
en laponie un sondage sur la tête elle
donc les mini aux maximes tu sais que je
t'aime docta but si tu veux pas je te
dis je le fais pas mais je t'aime fort
tu es sur maxi je vais le faire ici
alors attention
jusque là seul gilles vous allez
regarder et vous allez nous dire si vous
avez faire après pour faire gagner le
voyage aux canaries
attention c'est bien tenu et où là c'est
bien là on n'a pas de problème avec ça
là à lui pour christian on a peint peu
au peuple un technicien qui vérité j'ai
toujours un arrière bâbord c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon ça c'est
bon c'est sympa aux canaries direct star
et je vous le jure et ben on peut
laisser seul aime tellement que j'ai pas
pouvoir regarder j'ai pas pour rien
c'est bon non mais non j'attends très
bien parce qu'elle tient du manège
bordel de merde on a une foraine c'est
forcément ils ont vérifié juste avant
série là bas qui revêt lé fils bachir
vert et c'est mon héros des risques il
faut qu'il faut venir vérifier s'il vous
plaît alors on peut venir vérifier s'il
vous plaît aux téléspectateurs en direct
qui verrait maxime tu es bon franchement
sur les professionnels j'ai toute
confiance en deux temps les signes
monsieur maxime c'est l'attraction la
plus dallas tu vas monter à 60 mètres et
tu vas faire des allers retours comme un
avion de chasse
sinon ouais ouais voilà nom max tu sais
que je t'aime
c'est parfait autant il est dit monsieur
me dis si les mâles ont crié il démarre
pas adacore va traverser
merci attention attention rester molle
mais qui dit bonjour à la bbc
attention voilà pourquoi je sais partie
faut pas voir ça allait max c'est la
chute
un curé aucun mal à dire regardez comme
c'est à dire oh là là moi je peux pas
regarder ça
à
montreuil accord
ouais
m
[Musique]
je t'aime je te raconte tout c'est 7 5
vous avez fait je serais très bon bois
bien entendu en le pauvre maxime entendu
mal mc je dis de toi alors annette a dit
quoi que je mets ma dessous olala la
maison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
partira partira pas arrêter tous ces
beaux messieurs sera libéré la purée ça
va at on atteint un taux net en délibéré
le nom libérer le libérer le libérer
maximale en attendez attendez attendez
ça les poussoirs poussoir et yousra pour
tous les sorts de la bordel mais rennes
un bordel de merde mais notre temps
[Rires]
maxim maksimov site est exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]